this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is brought to you by our
supporters on patreon they get episodes
of this particular show early and adree
as well as totally unedited Cuts if we
have edits and a bunch of other cool
bonus content so if you want to support
this very independent show that runs
entirely without sponsorships make sure
you check us out on patreon also sorry
about the audio of this episode and last
episode I just had a recording issue
it'll be fixed next time I promise
speaking of which the the Apple Vision
Pro is finally coming out we haven't
spoken about it since the yeah I saw
some reviews started hitting have they I
haven't seen those yeah they're it's the
usual kind of very controlled kind of uh
demonstration process but um I've not
read any of them yet I don't know if
it's app Vision Pro
reviews because you were into right when
we spoke about it you were into the idea
of I love VR yeah and i' I've been a
fanboy of VR for a while I've made a few
things with it I've enjoyed it I I
really like it I'm
not I'm not convinced it's going to
catch se but there's just so many Nerds
like me who enjoy it that I I hope it
does um I I basically stopped making
games for it because I
realized I in order to match the quality
of what the VR specific devs were doing
I'd have to really commit to it and I I
like my console on my PC games too much
to kind of really dig in on VR you think
that um developing for VR is like an
entirely separate skill
set designing for VR definitely there's
obviously a lot of technical
similarities but like the the Leaps and
Bounds of like making a VR game feel
good are it's just it's you can do it
like we and we've done a couple of VR
games I would say are good but if I want
to excel at it I would have to commit to
it and I'm not it is an interesting one
I yeah there are a lot of VR games
that uh I feel like designing for a VR
game would be really hard um it that
that have VR mechanics that require you
know the player a move or whatever that
uh are not actually fun when sustained
so it's like they must have really
interesting design meetings in terms of
are we doing this because it adds a
layer of Freedom or are we doing this
because it adds a layer of enjoyment and
they aren't necessarily the same thing I
think a lot of the time with VR it's
like oh well that was fun the first time
I did it and I like that I can do that
and now I never want to do it again
which I always think that like I had
that with Red Dead Redemption 2 do I
want to see the animal be skinned every
time or was the one time good enough
probably just the one time was fine but
then the detail was there oh my God the
detail the dripping blood of the carcus
I I think it's a um yeah I think it goes
even even Beyond into kind
of remember what I was gonna [__] say
I it's quite late here so my brain has
just started to shut down sorry about
that I think it's just it's just it's an
incredibly skilled uh profession I've
been lucky enough to be in rooms with
very clever people on it in the past and
yeah it's going to require a whole new I
mean already there's a whole new
language to interaction in that space it
also though requires a lot of players
you know like I'm if I'm making a game
on like Xbox or PC like I got Ward I've
got twin sticks I've got face buttons
I've got you know that a is going to
select things on the menu like there's a
a whole uh you know a whole set of
grammar that Gamers know VR is has
developed some of that but it's just
very nent and again like it would be
exciting to be a part of that but also I
would have to really commit to it so
yeah I don't know if we'll do we we we
do a VR project I I I become nerdy and
do a VR project every like three years
or so so I'll probably come back to at
some point how different is that is the
approach um from a development point of
view it's very similar in that basically
you're you know you put a camera in the
world and and most of the most of the VR
comes with like solid apis for doing
kind of controller input the the like I
say the the main difference is design is
just thinking about as you said the
physical experience of playing a game
yeah you know what's fun what's good
all extremely regularly and that's one
mechanic and that's all I need and it
never gets boring but that's I guess
that's kind of my point is I look at
beat at beat saber and it's undeniably
cool and awesome but I don't as a game
designer know how to what's making it
great and awesome in the same way as
like I can look at it someone asked me
earlier actually to look at u a trailer
for a an indie platforming game and they
said the jump looks bad to me can you
explain why the Jump's bad and then I
bored that person for like 20 minutes
with like well actually I think what
they're doing here is they're doing this
on here and the coyote time is a bit too
blah blah and there's all that lingo and
and you know experience and knowledge
I've gained for a career VR would be a
reset so that's what puts me on from
yeah it's it's kind of that's exciting
in one sense and you know I'm it's very
exciting for people doing it but like
it's yeah
it's in your 30s you've got to start
closing doors um it's also a much
smaller
Market that's part of it as well for
sure yeah I mean I think still I've not
played everything obviously there are a
lot of VR games my favorite VR game is a
game called Kronos made by gunfire it's
in the same universe as the remnant
games um Kronos does it's effectively
like such a Cheesy way such a games
journalist way of explaining this but if
Dark Souls had it's if it's visceral
Dark Souls if Dark Souls had a Resident
Evil fixed camera like already one type
fixed camera um makes sense so you're
looking at like a diaram almost as
you're playing the game you're kind of
looking sort of it's dark souls Zelda is
what the actual game is but you have a
fixed camera and I think the reason I
like the fixed camera so much depending
on whatever room you walking whatever is
that um it really feels like it doesn't
feel like you are the play the the
protagonist it feels more like you are
front row watching a huge fight and so
when you get the scale of like a giant
enemy in front of you it's really just
cool yeah intimidating um but also the
puzzle solving from that perspective is
cool and I'm sure I would have spoken
about this before about this before
because I Rave about it all the time and
like brought it up at work uh the is a
mechanic that could only exist in VR
where they effectively have weeping
angels in that game so and I know I
didn't need to explain to you what that
was I make weeping angel references so
often and people like explain to the
audience there's going to be
yeah weeping angels is the Doctor Who
reference um the weeping angels
are uh statues that will move when you
aren't looking at them so if you turn
around they'll be like right behind you
or whatever um I hosted a do who podcast
before it went to Disney plus so like my
my my it's very true a lot of weeping
angels references I love them and I I
love them in video games too Angels
super cool um but in Kronos it there are
again I'm I'm basically giving any
statue that moves when you aren't
looking at it the term weeping angels
they're not actually called that in the
game but uh the weeping angels will move
when you yourself are not looking at
them not when your protagonist is not
near them so like I with my headset
would look at it and then like oh [__]
we have to go this way but I'm not
looking where my character is um because
they're too far behind or whatever so
I'll be like okay I have to figure out
where you need to go and then look back
and see if like you end up dead it's
like doing that quick so
pry much constantly like oh my god um
yeah really really cool in VR but I yeah
think every game should have more
weeping angel like generation of um was
it Moss the one with a mouse like a VR
game with a mouse I really enjoyed back
in the day which was very simple kind of
little action platformer Kronos might
have even come out before Moss uh no way
do yeah Kronos uh game uh VR Kronos is
such a like generic word
um it's like 70 games
yeah Kronos came
out yeah it was gunfire games who made
it they got pretty pretty solid reviews
across the board trouble finding the
release date
2016 uh oh wow yeah I love it uh Moss
game VR also the same time or later like
saying I think a little bit later
because it was Moss was psvr I think um
2018 was so yeah chronist 2016 and still
stands out to me as one of my absolute
favorites apparently I gave it an8 out
of 10 on IGN I may play that on Apple
Vision who knows I love it we'll see
super fun um but yeah the the Apple
Vision it looks like they like you said
they are carefully orchestrating Vision
Pro reviews with multiple meetings
whatever that means I've never really
heard like it's like an old school kind
of game demo where you go to the studio
and sit in the room and play their demo
you know do all that yeah YouTubers and
members of the media selected for
reviews will meet without your right yet
with apple on January 16 for hands-on
experience with a follow-up meeting to
take place on January 23rd to go over
the devices features a second time so
you I mean those sound more like a
Hands-On demo and less like a review I
don't feel like it really counts as a
review unless you're taking it home but
I'm not Apple uh I I think every choice
that Apple makes is is good and above
reproach that's my view wow that's very
of you wow okay yeah
I'm you I'm a controversial guy honestly
after after my ranting last week I'm I'm
saying calm this we no I was good
disagree with me
baby it was that it was that no surprise
that Apple plans to have firm hold on
the review if it were anyone else I
would assume that that was a negative uh
but I don't feel that way about Apple
it's like it's got to be scary having a
piece of tech like that that is like
nothing that most people will ever have
even tried and be like go ahead review
it
I like it's very it's it's yeah I it's
it's it seems cool from the outside I'm
excited to try one I 100% we'll pick one
up and have it go at some point um I
don't know if I'll buy one I think
they're pretty expensive at launch so
I'll probably that's my issue too
expensive find a friend and borrow it
yeah how much was it a launch like four
five grand something uh that's I think
it's a few Grand Vision Pro pre-
Auto for me to get one
right
now PR start haven't started yet but
soon right okay oh my God the Apple
website does just give me the
information this is just a lot of foot
scroll down over pounding lifestyle
shots it is actually very fancy no
doesn't even have the price on there
anyway you sons of [__] yeah if you
got to ask you can't afford it I guess
it's the logic oh yeah if they're trying
to hide it there's a reason for that but
apparently pre-orders begin um January 9
19 which will be out of date by the time
we publish this episode so pre-orders
we're already
up just give me the [__] price
somebody every this is this is
journalism what we're doing right
now type cost off
$3,500
us damn that is that is a big investment
to make especially for something that we
don't know how and for a first gen Apple
product which you know usually best away
you love the company what do you mean
but I love the company I love the
company they're
great the company all company is great I
like all companies I'm a big company fan
in general you know I mean big company
guy you know me yeah capitalism it's
great it's a good idea as the only one
of us that owns a company I mean but
still you have employed I I I like all
companies uh that uh that are named off
to me and they're
great absolutely no bias
involved um so there was this thing that
I wanted to talk to you about that uh
leans in a little bit to our
conversation that we were just having
about are we getting a segue we it's
like a I segwayed but like I had to leap
over something in order to make the
segue work um okay okay P attention to
it we fine yeah pretend that we didn't
talk
about um speaking of like you know what
components
VR uh make good game design in terms of
like what's fun to the player or what's
like just you just did it because you
should do it
um I I think that happens with a lot of
video games is like you think you should
do something but it's not necessarily
that player enjoyment I also I'm sure
said this on the show before that a lot
of games criticism I didn't think about
this until I started working in De
full-time was um people will complain
about things that they don't necessarily
actually want um and this tweet from
Patrick Mills uh who welcome Austin um
welcome Austin to the show I know from
is work on cyberp Punk um he said genre
discussions are always pointless and
irritating except for the ones that say
immersive Sims are the best kind of game
and all games can be rated in quality by
what percentage of immersive Sim they
are he said which is simply correct an
uncontroversial opinion and I was like
you know what I actually do think when
it comes to the critical reception of
video games most Gamers heavily favor
anything that has more immersive Sim
elements that is what what the YouTube
audience considers to be a real video
game is is how much qualtity of that
game is immersive Sim or
not is that immersive Sim or is that
just like interactivity as a concept
like how much the player can express
themselves in the same for for the
purpose of the discussion for most
players right yeah yeah does that mean
that you're defining that genre does
that genre get to be the the torch
Bearer for player agency is that
essentially what that boils down to it's
it sort of has to be I think I think it
sort of is
um simulation in general I think is
largely thought of as the most
interactive genre right in terms of all
self-expressive yeah but OS of sim is
also like
usually uh you know you do one Quest and
and that locks you out of 10 others is
like generally something that really
appeals to people in terms of
conversation but I don't know how much
it appeals to people terms of playing it
of your experience maybe even more so
than interaction how bespoke what your
experien a thing to do well this is the
whole thing that we're constantly told
and I've been in several like you know
marketing people conversations where the
same's been expressed of like that is
the big generational shift that has
occurred is that you know our
Generations collectively value ownership
and the generation after us values
unique experience and and and in terms
of both having an authentic unique
experience themselves but also being
able to share that experience on social
media and kind of can you elaborate on
that you're saying that our generation
is in like
Millennials I'm I'm I'm lumping you in
with the Millennials you're you're
you're like at the Young end of
millennial or are you at the old end of
I'm Millennial by three years okay so
yeah Millennials historically um we are
like we are there's there's an a school
of thought which seems to be backed up
by a lot of like financial data which we
are like the last materialistic
generation in the sense that we like to
collect and own
stuff there's always out lies of course
you're GNA find a collector who's
younger and you're gonna find a
millennial who doesn't own anything
obviously but the large the consensus
seems to be that our generation collects
and owns and hordes and fills our spaces
with stuff and the generation below us
and this is often blamed on social media
um have grown up to prize unique
experience or going places or they spend
more on restaurants and clubs and
tourism than our generation did as a
comparable price bracket yeah or a
comparable sorry income bracket when
when when we were earning X the Next
Generation earning X spends a larger
percentage of that money on experience
than there's lots of reasons arguing for
that another one is dating and the way
that dating has kind of turned into a um
has people are dating more than they did
in our generation because of apps and
stuff like that so there's just a lot of
interesting trends that pulled in that
direction so a lot of companies um the
sectors of their businesses uh which are
focused on entertainment and tourism are
doing better than they're um yeah
selling physical
objects I wonder
why it's usually blame on social media
that we're very that the generation
beneath us is more performative than us
in terms of their in terms of what
they're doing whereas we we perform by
having a bookshelf full of stuff when
people come over the next Generation
performs by putting up an image on
Instagram of them in a cool venue yeah
sure I know that like Fast fashion is a
huge New Generation thing you could
argue that's a transition of clothing
into experiential it is it's buying
something for $6 to wear it once on your
Instagram feed and then never wearing it
again so it is sort of the same thing it
is uh yeah making clothing experiential
which is actually super interesting like
it's it's probably a big generalization
like to be clear if you're watching this
and you're a 15-year-old with 10,000
vinyl then fair enough but like yeah
there's definitely that's the trend that
people that 15y olds that that yeah that
person gets my
yeah that's a cool maybe Gamers maybe
the generation of Gamers is is going in
a similar Direction maybe the gamer who
wants to buy something play it for 10
hours and then put it on their shelf is
being replaced by the player who wants
to post a cool video of them doing
something interesting on the internet
you know and and and a more immersive
Simi game would lean in that direction I
don't know I also I I've I've related to
this I have wondered what the kind
of you know the kind of thorough
analysis would look like that that
reconciles all these independent threads
because the other thing that is an
interesting seemingly Stark generational
divide is I have never despite having
friends who do it even present company
included I've never really understood
the appeal of watching someone stream
playing a game I've never I've you know
it's like it's it's a it is a and it's
it's not one of those where it baffles
me to the point where I'm like you're an
idiot you're wasting your time it's more
just I don't it's not fun other than
certain kinds of games and this is where
I was where I'm kind of going with it is
is that I would think that the more
immersive Sim type thing where you play
it and you realiz you watch someone play
it rather and you realize oh they're
doing things totally different than what
I would do I would be curious to see the
difference in my play was play BS Gate 3
a lot of people had like those kind of
comments of enjoying watching other
people play because it's the only way to
get an idea of how big the game is yeah
I remember I remember
um uh playing through her story with my
ex and where I just said I'll just I'm
just gonna be your I'm like your conduit
you're so I basically obviously the only
thing you really do in that game is type
words into the search but I had played
through the game and loved it and then
so I sat there going okay you know you
just tell me what to type and it was
amazing how within one search it was a
different game entirely already I mean
it was just like the things that you
into it and so that's to me that's a big
sort of if so much of your game
consumption as with Gen Z is about
watching someone play it behooves the
developer I would think to have
something that can be wildly different
from one play through to the next you
know whereas like has purchasing value
you've not just seen somebody play
through the whole thing like yeah still
you're more likely to buy
it I mean we even seen that with our
visual novels like you know and that's
obviously nowhere near the variety of
something like a Boulders gate I'm I bet
the same is true of your game Austin
musical like having the your having that
seeing that one path through the game
and then immediately going here's three
places I have done something different
or even even if you just want to see the
variety I've I've I've spoken to players
who've bought the game purely because
they just wanted to see where they could
kick the corners of the game you know
where they could find
stuff yeah I I and I I I do get that
actually and that's one of those funny
things where as much as I am really not
gen Z and you know 99 you are Austin you
are a no come on now you could be day
over
30 oh god um as much uh yeah as much as
I'm I'm uh like philosophically in a
different place in so many ways I I do
actually relate to that impulse as a
gamer where um the the sort of
Spider-Mans and the last of uses Etc of
the world that when I was younger were
overwhelmingly my interest like I played
strategy games and MMOs and things like
that um which are a lot closer to the
immersive Sim side of things but
generally speaking it was all about you
know I want I want to go through the
motions of a great story but I do find
myself like by far when I got my steam
stat rundown far in a way uh balers
skate was my number one for last year I
mean by like people right three to one
ratio compared to Second Place i' played
a lot of smaller uh uh indie games last
year that I thought were really really
fun but the game that I spent the most
time in was balis Gate 3 Starfield was
second um and even then I don't feel
like I've even scratched the surface on
Boulders Gate 3 and I do think Starfield
was you leaving it going flying for 10
towards
some I did play a fair bit of that game
um but but Boulders Gate 3 there's
something so appealing about feeling
like I haven't even touched
it Zelda feels similar I guess I yeah
look that's absolutely terrifies me I'm
gonna play it because obviously it's
such an important and cool game but like
that's really intimidating to me I I I
love a five hour game I hear about all
the time on this show I love it too
I'm I'm hyped I was actually a little
bit put off I'm really excited big
Prince Persia fan so I'm really excited
for Prince
pers yeah so but I was I'll be honest I
saw a review of it that said it was 20
hours long and I was
like I'm gonna but still like that's a
shame yeah exactly I was like oh I don't
like that much value in the game no what
are you doing it is funny how that is I
guess it's an
interesting like that's generational
well you've got less time as you age
right that's I remember sinking I
remember DSX Human Revolution playing
that as a teenager for like six seven
different story when I was in high
school I didn't have [__] to do what do
I
care see know these young people I watch
Benjamin Button the other day which
explores this as a thing never SE
Benjamin Button no You' never seen it
odd movie it's I love that movie I I
recognize all of the things that people
take issu lik it yeah not least of which
that it's so beat for beat comparable to
Forest Gump well say writers so fair
play yeah and like there's a lot of ABS
you can make that scan through the whole
Benjamin goes
running it's it's well it's just that
Benjamin running is a theme in some
places one's feather one's about
hummingbird it's not the same and the
dipping in and out of kind of like
historically significant times and
places and and narrated by Southern draw
you know there's there it's it's Brad
Pitt full into me with a Vampire mode
which I like that's my kind of broad
there's just something that I found so
wistful about that film that got under
my skin admittedly part of it was that I
was so head over heels in love with
displ score to that movie that it was
just like it it basically made all the
rest of it electrified and I would touch
it and it just it just instantly was in
all my cells but um but yeah it to me
it's it's so unfin it's like it's
definitely watch it again though it's
darker than I assumed it would be B
because I'd had the same conversation
with people over the years why I never
watched it CU I like the proper grownup
mature it's actually kind of a dark
cynic it's got some of that Fincher
cynicism that I that I love like that
kind of or not cynicism that's too
strong a word I don't remember anything
in inherently cynical if if anything
it's like a fairy tale uh there's a
fairy tale oh it's about death it's the
threat of death and the knowledge of
death and what it does to our planning
and our lives it's it's got It's it's
under the surface there there's that
undercurrent but I never read it I I
would I would argue it has exactly that
quality but in a beautiful quiet
acceptance kind of like that shot sure
you know on the little uh bench looking
out over the lake to me is very
emblematic where it's just you know our
time will come I love that we're all
gonna die but that's okay that's that's
about as that that is vure at his most
sweet and sugary in fness we gonna die
but that's okay don't worry about it
yeah it's it's it's it's there's that
great scene where they
uh Kate Blanchett and Brad Pit are
finally both like around 40 and they've
kind of intersected for the first and
only time and they know they're gonna
you know she'll get
older and they're and they that scene of
them lying next to each other where you
know they say I was just thinking about
how some things you know will kind of
what's the exact line it's like some
things uh nothing's forever or something
that yeah exactly something's never uh
stopped changing or or or yeah something
never lasts forever what a shame that is
and just kind of looks at him and says
some things last forever and it's just
this poignant little moment and there
similarly where they in her like dance
ballet space just looking at each other
in the mirror going let's try to
remember this moment where we know
forever this will be the only time that
we ever kind of look comparable to one
another something about just
the this to me this is the correct
application of nostalgia it's like this
wistful longing of a
thing that you know is incredibly
fleeting that movie captured that for
some reason so immaculately to me again
I recognize SC did a lot of heavy
lifting in creating it because course
it's just it's just a spot on I was it's
that pain isn't it Nostalgia like that's
the isn't that the original definition
of nostalgia is it's actually about it's
a painful thing Nostalgia is not a
positive it's a I always associated with
that yeah it's it is the it is the
emotion associated with something that
you loved and lost
yeah it's not it's the modern use of
nostalgia as in like recapturing your
youth that's not what the where the word
originates it's it's the it's the Pang
of pain you feel well remembering that
you're no longer there speak spending a
lot of money I think a lot of that is
Nostalgia spending I have spent a lot of
money on Pokemon as an adult like a lot
which apparently so is everyone else I
mean it's the highest grossing franchise
in existence right Pokemon Mak more
money than anything else um I've spent I
think I knew that yeah I know it's nuts
Pokemon is number one in terms of I mean
there's so many ways in yeah and I think
a lot of it
is
people like it's funny because Pokemon's
motto from the start has got to catch
them all right you tell me that when I'm
six years old and I'm like I need all of
this uh and that's happening to me as a
kid and I did still want all of them my
mom was getting me like booster packs
once a month on a Friday or whatever um
and then you grow up and you still got
to catch them all but now you can afford
to catch more of them so it's just
Millennials just funding Pokémon to
fulfill a childhood want that we got
indoctrinated by on the every part
that's got to factor in right that's got
to factor into like people creating new
franchises for like kids you've got to
there's got to be at this point like a
40-year plan right of how you're going
to go back to that kid in the future and
resell them this I've heard it happens
with um Disney with well Disney do
nothing terrible at all um the uh but
like I've definitely heard I've
definitely heard it said that around
like reboots sequels that there is a
specific Cadence that you go for so you
can get like specifically like with old
bringing back like old franchises like
something like jamanji there's a
specific I think it is it 20 years The
Nostalgia Loop there's like a specific
timing that you're meant to hit with a
franchise because that's the point where
there will be parents who want to take
their children to it because they loved
it get that multigenerational Loop going
I can't remember there's a specific
thumb to yeah I've heard definitely
heard that before I can't remember what
the what the numbers were but yeah
there's I I I assume that's got to be a
factor like and and and how to hit
people at different ages how to how to
get Al Lana to still want to catch them
all every couple of years how we going
to hit you with messaging on that how we
going to remind you conly doing some
really interesting stuff um where yeah
I'm sure that I'm being marketed to
because my God it keeps working but um I
am also been priced out of a couple of
recent releases where I can't afford the
Pokemon stuff that I want like on the
cards no um the recent cards are pretty
affordable I mean that happen certainly
with uh people reselling but no they had
a Tiffany
collaboration uh so it
was that's how you know certain age Gap
yeah yeah
exactly when your demographic has like
financially to certain I couldn't afford
it and and I was like this [__] sucks
like give me this but with anyone
cheaper than Tiffany and then they
recently just did what what on Earth was
the collabor what is a Tiffany meets
Pokemon item what does that even
literally mean
honestly an hour to come up with a pun
response to that Austin I'm gonna sit
down with some of my best writing
friends we're gonna come up with 10
jokes look forward I can't I can't hit
that quickly enough so it was a collab
Jimmy and Pikachu is forming in my head
I'm not there yet there you're getting
there I'll get there I'll work it out it
was a collaboration with Daniel Asam who
is uh an artist that I really like in
general like I highly recommend checking
out his stuff I have some of his Pokemon
stuff that is also very expensive um but
frankly it's pretty ugly which is the
craziest part so you've got these uh
just sort of Pokemon that look like
they've been eaten into and they have
diamonds and so there there's charms
There's a pikachu necklace uh there's a
necklace with a bunch
yeah that's sort of a bit of Daniel Aram
style
Decay that I actually really like but
could not afford the Tiffany and Co
collaboration it look bit like zombie
Pikachu though there's
definitely I didn't remember his F but
I've totally seen this I yeah I love his
art and and I do have three of his um
statues that are not cheap but I still
can AFF the Tiffany and then there was
also did the Tiffany come in that little
poke ball
with no and that's the problem it's like
[__] I want it because it's Pokemon uh
there's also a Pokemon family
collaboration that just launched um a
couple months ago again devastatingly
can't afford it uh I have one friend who
bought it and it was I mean she's rich
and I was like [__] you God damn it um
where basically fendy bags with
Dragonites on them I it's just it's been
really interesting to watch uh just came
out on January 4th apparently um I
imagine I don't even remember the prices
you know I I remember looking and being
like not for me uh where Pokemon is now
getting so many Big Brand collaborations
that I can't afford it and now it's like
what are these 50y olds like who can
afford any of this like I don't know who
these people what who you making these
for CU you'll see a lot of people really
slighted about the price uh in any of
the comment sections um because you're
like I've been here since the '90s and
Tiffany [__] you and I'm like I get it
man I get it uh they have to make the
choices I was gonna say the return on
investment has got to some has to work
out I mean absolutely yeah it's the the
people exist if you were if you were in
high school in the mid to late 990 like
when did the cartoon first come out I
was a bit too old for Pokemon so I think
late 90s PK yeah late the movie was um
yeah 2000 I think you're the same were
are you born the same year as rul Mike
because R always says the same thing he
was like a little bit too old for
Pokemon don't we have like the same
birthday or something or we're close
he's November 13
1985 yeah I was born I I came along six
days earlier just to kind of get the
ground work ready before he showed up
you know just to yes so we're a bit me
and ra yeah us two were a bit too old
for Pokemon because I remember my little
sister would have been uncool right yeah
it was like we were grown-ups basically
yeah we were we would have been in that
age bracket where you stop playing with
the children's toys for 10 years
disgusting get the Pang of nostalgia and
come back to yeah yeah my sister was
born in 89 and she wasn't too old like
she liked Pokemon almost as much as I
did 89 yes that would be how old would
that person be now like 34 35 how's your
sister uh my sister is
34 yeah yeah yeah so that's your Peak
Pokemon and yes so there's 34 year olds
who can afford Tiffany necklace that's
true just ain't me um so the games
Pokemon games first came out in
1996 uh at least that's when green came
out um and yeah I mean I know 2000
because the 2000 movie that's the first
movie I remember seeing C whatever but
it is interesting the whole generation
of people who like Pokemon's had a huge
impact on that now like now that I'm
decorating a home I have a ton of
Pokemon art I have kitchen towels
there's like stuff that if needed a Pog
I'd be there that would be my oh my God
any any minute now Austin's face The Joy
on Austin's face for the what Punk was
well it was like weirdly mixed where I'm
like oh man how did I get so into that
it's funny it was for a
week had to have those crazy those crazy
heavy ass metal Slammers see if I feel
happy during this conversation doesn't
that prove the negative Theory correct
incorrect no see here's where South Park
I think correctly modified the
vocabulary Nostalgia I think is supposed
to be exactly supposed to be a kind of
slightly hang in the chest wistful
memory like visiting a cemetery and
looking at a grandparents headstone or
something and remembering great times
memberberries is the cynical I'm gonna
feed you that dopamine hit as low cost
as possible by just recycling a thing
you already know and if it if it Taps
into that thing that you were in that
magical kind of 12 to 18 range uh it's
going to hit you at your maximum point I
like to fight that by playing great
games like identity that's my that's
what I do shut
up I uh recently made a video that was
directed at uh it's about stand-up
comedians but
um I did a bunch of
digging no in in different about the
stand-up comedians it's more about how
we
routinely um they all advertise with the
same Politically Incorrect and we yell
about everything they say on social
media every time and it just helps them
really um that they're
all a meeting room in Netflix and
they're like okay what's the most
controversial thing in definitely think
so and say it early so you get to make
the joke of like making sure the [__]
are gone and it's really um but it was
effectively about that but I did some
some digging into like the notion that
like humans have always been sensitive
has always been my thesis we're just
sensitive to different things in
different periods of time so like when
everyone is like you're too sensitive
for jokes these days I'm like well you
people used to be jailed for standup you
used to be jailed for swearing in the
street you used to have rocks thrown at
You for Cheating that's pretty [__]
sensitive um and part of that was I
found this series of articles about a
bunch of different facets of nostalgia
that were really interesting to read
through multiple like spans of time and
the baseball one was the most
interesting one I found sorry if I've
spoken about this on the podcast before
because again I found it really
interesting people will say oh baseball
was so much better when I was a kid um
and you can find that repeated over and
over and over again every decade you
know since baseball began and it from
what I could figure out from piecing
these things together and from reading a
thesis on it um you will say that based
on what age you were when you developed
critical thinking so when you say this
was better when I was a kid the cut off
for that is say you were 12 and that's
when you started to realize that your
dad wasn't perfect or realize that your
teacher wasn't the coolest gu guy you'd
ever met or realize whatever was wrong
with other people everything before that
because you can't retroactively give
yourself critical thinking is perfect uh
and you you don't have the ability to to
change how you feel about that because
you can't [__] go back in time and
assess it critically so there's no
critic written the disc without copy
protection the age of 12 and then so
whenever you think it was better in my
day is exactly before you developed the
ability to criticize things which I just
found to be
so the the the the thing of nostalgia
for an age before you is fascinating as
well I remember when I was working on
volume it's a Robin Hood game so I did a
lot of research and like the history of
the Robin Hood mythology a lot of which
was written in the Victorian era because
the victorians were [__] obsessed
with Medieval Times like because that
was the back then that was the Glorious
era of the past was medieval times
before we had all these new fangled
Industrial Technologies the the the idea
of like romance the romance era arur and
Legend Robin Hood all of that stuff I
suppose I feel like that about the 80s
and I wasn't alive for it exactly and
you see this a lot with like yeah know
people people are often nostalgic for as
they W what they're actually what you're
actually nostalgic for with the 80s was
you probably like Back to the Future as
a kid right like there was there was
content you consumed or media that you
were aware of and it's depiction of the
80s it may even be that I watched those
things before I developed critical
thinking and thus the 80s equals perfect
it could be I mean I I think I really
liked the '90s too um but still what was
seven when the night it's also what you
hear parents and grandparents talking
about as a kid and and those things
sound cool to you or whatever you know
that makes sense there's lots
of of evidence that shows also that when
we mythologize this stuff we're pretty
much always wrong y that anybody that
goes oh when I was a kid everything was
so much better y for XYZ reasons and he
just asked someone who was 30 at the
time and they're like well you just had
no awareness yeah of all these things
completely undermine your your
contention I've always found that very
reassuring when I was because it makes
you realize things aren't orders of
magnitude worse today that people 50
years ago and 100 years ago and 150
years ago were more or less concluded
things were on the precipice of
apocalypse and that we have since we
started stuff down there's been
apocalyptic predictions s for the whole
of human
history phenomen most it's it's there's
a did I say this on the last episode of
this show there's like a psychological
theory that that's actually built into
us to help us deal with the idea of our
own death I swear I said this on
probably speaking about deny doubt like
I mean it makes sense to me that you if
you want the whole world to end when you
went it does it's not comfortable to
think that the world will just carry on
without you that's a horrible thought
yeah yeah I may have I may have brought
it up I don't think I brought it up in
that conversation but I may have in the
past that I when I was in my degree you
know composition programs and taking one
of the music history courses I was
reading this there was a reproduced
letter there's this very famous composer
from the kind of first halfish of the
20th century named Charles IES who was
kind of this closet genius he was an
insurance salesman who wrote All these
insanely Progressive Avant guard pieces
of music that just laugh people
essentially found in a drawer after he
was dead and we're like what the hell
the most imaginative and Forward
Thinking composer alive was just this
ious insurance salesman and so Charles
Ives is a is a deeply fascinating
composer for for analysis and I remember
coming across this letter that he was
like you know kids these days can just
don't have the attention span to
appreciate proper music and what artists
are trying to do and the letter was
dated like 1905 or something like that
where it was it was it was hilarious I
mean it was just you couldn't have
possibly written a
more translatable to today even just the
phing of it was so again very human
right there's records of there's is it
it's Socrates or Aristotle or someone
one of one of the great Greek
philosophers who literally wrote a
treaties about how awful kids today were
and that they didn't take anything
seriously like it's it's again it's
we're we're humans we're we are
basically the same as Generations before
us we just have slightly better tools
and education and the people before us
but the fundamentals of The Human
Condition haven't shifted fundamentally
I asked my dad what was like growing up
in the ' 80s um and he was like you know
we didn't really worry about anything we
just went places we just did stuff you
wenter worried about the stuff you
worried about today and then I told D
grew up in the 80s no but he was alive
like what was it like to exist not grow
up sorry it's my fault you the BR up you
calling her D
liar I'm just I'm like I'm like wow very
young young procreated young he was born
in
austral I think maybe yeah I don't
remember any he was hanging out in the
80s uh and he existed years old he
existed um I think I was 70s and ' 80s
whatever who cares point is I was like
you know crime rates uh where you grew
up Dad have decreased since you were a
kid like you know that because I know
exactly where he grew up obviously and
and he was like I don't believe that and
so I pulled up the statistics which is
truly my most annoying quality and um
the the data it's I really have to stop
but I can't help myself like well I've
got some daa um just let people be wrong
it's fine it's but I can't do it we'll
get there he didn't believe me so I
pulled up the daa and I was like it's
just that you see it you just have more
access to information that's all it is
like that the things haven't gone to
[__] it's just that you see it more but
I also think like as you get older
saying things have gone to [__] and I
don't want to be part of that generation
and everything is bad again just makes
you feel better about dying why are we
talking about dying so much this
year yeah are we
okay not is it we're getting close to
it's because we know AI are taking our
jobs I think that's what maybe
yeah and we're getting close to 150
episodes which is pretty old the when
you said the other day that we've been
doing this for over four years actually
broke my brain isn't that crazy br my
brain I couldn't process that it feels
like too yeah considering considering
that uh this year I'll turn 40 that
means that this podast will have been
10% of my
life that's a horrible thought that's
astonishing look at us it is actually
quite shocking because it still feels
like such this new people see we do
actually record seven days a week we
just trim it the most interesting yeah
we just have an open we actually just
live on this call the live stream yeah
this is the original Zoom none of us has
ever rebooted a computer or anything in
the last four years it's like the uh the
zoom of
thesis that's the most playwatch listed
joke that has ever happened I
should Zoom
of that's how you
abely that's going to be a not Mak this
to be watched no that's why it doesn't
matter if I call it Zoom of thesias
sometimes like titling the episodes I
don't know to call this one we could
talk briefly about something
controversial and popular if you like
just we got a lot of views on recently
um we recently got a bunch of views on
the episode where we talked about
everything that was wrong with unity so
oh that's yeah drama
that's and then my most recent favorite
thumbnail is the one where canvas is
attacking Austin and Austin is
laughing yep yep she's
she's she's
delightful like I know Zeta males or
something no Sigma Sigma males the new
one is let's talk about Sigma males for
five minutes yeah we should probably
talk about how like women uh need to um
to how how many men has women had sex
with and is allowed body count yeah is
that allowed no is that is it should
woman sex should woman sex have any of
you seen poor things
no not yet hated it um I know that I
have a very unpopular take there it's
been lorded hated it hated it no idea
what this is did also recently watch one
flow over the cooko nest thought it was
pretty good and also saw sh Shank
Redemption for the first time thought it
was
perfect sh Shank Redemption we we tried
to go you into watching that on the show
before that was a Mike plan again he was
outraged that I had not seen it and was
like told that you hadn't seen sh sh
redemp I wouldn't yeah but it means that
I get to watch it in his cool home
theater so I did a good experience if
you're gonna watch sh Shank Redemption
with anyone watching with my CL when I
told him that I didn't love one FL over
the cucko nest he was concerned um but
they're very different movies uh one
flow with the cooko nest is there a
summary of what you bounced off of about
it um I understand why it's a classic
and it's very unique and I think the
performances are incredible I bounced
off of the and then it's very much uh
and then this happens and then this
happens and then this happens and not a
lot of therefore um like this person did
this which caus to this it does more of
like and then and then and then and then
he shows up and then he breaks out and
then this um so I just wasn't a fan of
the way the story was told but loved the
performances uh it also didn't leave me
feeling too much like I was like I
enjoyed it uh that's sad but
what and I think that like that you
could have made interesting commentary
on like dictatorship probably with that
movie but they kind of opted not to um
anyway I still liked it I just didn't I
just didn't love it uh whereas shank
again I was like this is the perfect
film what what you better sh Shang
Redemption is the perfect film In
fairness like it is utterly perfect
brilliant loved it yeah top to bottom
fantastic um it's so I just looked up
app PL synopsis for poor things and now
I have to watch it that is a wild
it again have you seen saltburn no which
not I want to see is it just Talented Mr
Ripley because that's how when people
sounds I've seen Talented Mr Ripley I
like Talented Mr Ripley I don't
necessarily need to watch it again it's
Talented Mr Ripley but with a much
heavier lens
towards uh like class
difference um it's very much about
analyzing this like hyper aristocratic
family and the way they view the rest of
the world that that put it puts so much
through that lens but it is a strongly
Talented Mr rimple kind of cuz I
remember I watched It's a Ripley like
that's what we call video G it's an
immersive Ripley like somehow not
an balers likes and people get so pissed
off about it like you never [__]
heard of crpg but I think calling
something a balers like is much funnier
that is fun I've got screenshots of
people being furious at me for it Ripley
like is very good too though like just
take the the nearest thing and call it a
something all other podcasts are a play
watch listen
like any any format of people talking
yeah it's a playwatch listen like
actually I don't think anyone else does
this I think I think we're the only
podcast
people STS is a playwatch listen like
with music
elements um and that's what the reviews
were
missing probably should have covered it
that's
true uh in any case I like it
I have to get back to work um I don't
know what I'm going to call this episode
what did you say the ship of Theus
the a second good we like it that's such
a that's such a uh Brad Sigma
males Sil I just love I just love the
idea of of someone watching wondering
when the payoff of that title is going
to come along and
then Ying so incredibly
unsatisfying there's a lot of freedom in
not caring if anybody watches this it's
working out really
well I occasionally look at the YouTube
and see ones up and read a comment or
two but other than that I'm completely
unaware that anyone's watching this
that's probably could stop uploading
them and it would be fine we just have a
little chat once a week that's kind of
why we're still here really so great um
I'm Al I'm a video game writer That's
Mike bethl he is a video game director
that's awesome when he's a video game G
composer and we will see you next
time